Solve for y and
check your solution.
20 minus 7y is
equal to 6y minus 6.
So what I really
want to just do is
isolate all of the y's on
one side of this equation.
And then if there's some
coefficient in front of it,
I can divide both sides
by that coefficient.
And I could isolate the
y on either the left side
or the right side
of the equation.
Actually, let me
do it both ways.
So first, it looks like it'll
be a little bit simpler if I
isolate it on the
right hand side,
and I'll show you
that in a second.
So if I want to put all of the
Y's on the right hand side,
how could I get rid of the
Y's on the left hand side?
I have a minus 7y, or you
could use the negative 7y.
I can add 7y to both
sides of this equation.
So I'm just adding
7y to both sides.
Then the left hand
side of the equation--
we have 20 minus 7y plus 7y.
Those are going to cancel out.
You're going to be
just left with 20.
And on the right hand
side of the equation,
you're going to have 6y
plus 7y, which is 13y.
And then you have your minus 6.
And I want only
y's, or multiples
of y's, on the right hand
side of the equation.
So I need to get rid of
this minus 6 over here.
So let's add 6 to both
sides of this equation.
And then on the right hand
side, I have 13y minus 6 plus 6.
That's just 13y-- got
rid of the minus 6.
And I have 20 plus 6.
So that is 26.
So I get 26 is equal to 13y.
I've isolated the y on
the right hand side,
although it's being
multiplied by 13.
So if I just want a y
on the right hand side
or 1y on the right hand side,
I can divide both sides by 13.
Or the equivalent
statement would
be to multiply both sides
by 1 over 13-- same thing.
So let's divide both sides
of this equation by 13.
On the right hand side,
13 times y divided by 13.
Well, that's just going to be y.
So this is just y.
And then 26 divided
by 13-- that is 2.
So our solution we got
is y is equal to 2.
Now I want to take a step back.
Why did I say it would
be a little bit easier
to put the y's on the right
hand side of the equation?
Well, because that's the way
I got a positive coefficient
in terms of y.
I got 13y.
If I had subtracted
6y from both sides,
I would have got a negative 13
on the left hand side, which
would have been a
legitimate thing to do.
Let me just show you
what I'm talking about.
So I could have done the
problem this way-- 20 minus
7y is equal to 6y minus 6.
Now let me just subtract
6y from both sides.
So minus 6y, or negative
6y, from both sides.
The left hand side over
here is 20 minus 13y.
The right hand side--
I got rid of that 6y.
I just have the minus 6 here,
or it's just a negative 6 now.
And now I can subtract
20 from both sides
to isolate the y's on
the left hand side.
So I'm subtracting
20 from both sides.
I'm doing that to
get rid of this 20.
And so on the left hand
side, I have a negative 13y,
and on the right hand
side, I have a negative 26.
Now I want to divide both
sides of this equation
by negative 13,
and what do I get?
Negative 13 times something
divided by negative 13
is just that something.
I just get a y.
And then negative 26
divided by negative 13 is 2.
So I did it two different ways.
Over here, I isolated the
y's on the left hand side.
Over here, I did it on
the right hand side.
I picked the right
hand side first
so that everything
stays positive,
but this is an equally
valid way to do it.
Now the last thing I want
to do is just make sure
that we got the right answer.
We should probably feel
pretty comfortable.
We got the same answer
doing it two different ways,
but let's actually check it.
Let's put y equal 2
back into the equation
and verify that we
get the equality.
So we have 20 minus 7y is 2.
So 7 times 2 should be
equal to 6 times 2 minus 6.
So this should be 20 minus 14.
I want to do multiplication
first-- order of operations.
So this is 20 minus 14
should be equal to 6 times
2 is 12 minus 6.
20 minus 14 is 6.
12 minus 6 is 6.
6 is, indeed, equal to
6, so it all checks out.